well you kind of do not you kind of do
you do everything like actress singer
book was in the bestselling New York
Times bestseller list you're doing
products you're doing it's just like and
I've started doing that too but I I do
it and I I think you do it like for this
as well for this reason is is I do
things like I'm coming out with a a
children's book and I always wanted to
make one and Simon and Shuster are
putting it out in June and it's really
have to ask you for a quote on the back
conations yes it's and it's just like
look is it a money maker no but I wanted
to do it I've always wanted to do it so
I'm doing things I'm coming out with a
pet product I'm like you know and it's
just called you know Rosie something I
can't tell you exactly what it is yet
but um and I just I was working with my
friend I'm like let's just do this this
will be fun if it's not a big risk if it
doesn't work oh well so I like I started
it took me a long time but I always was
chasing things that chasing after things
that people wanted me to do you have to
act you have to do this what are you
doing wasting your time what and I'm
like so I was doing things based really
on what other people wanted my agent my
business manager even some friends then
I thought is it what you want to do what
do you want to do well I want to make
music I'm not the best singer in the
world but I can sing and I can write
songs and I want to do it for me I don't
want to be a rock star or make millions
it'd be nice but I'm doing it for me do
you find that the old older you get you
start to do more of that yes and it's
beautiful but isn't it frustrating that
we wait so long yeah I have this
conversation with my kids all the time
eight and 10 and I'm already like guys
spend your life doing things you really
want to do like spend your life doing
that
because you're happy when you're doing
things that you really want to do and I
get it like Hollywood is this very
specific pocket of time and by the way
people that said to me hey you know what
let's not go to college right now like
really want to I really wanted to go to
college and they were like you could go
to college and you would have an amazing
time but you're also like on this
trajectory right now like just keep it
going keep the train moving because it's
Hollywood you never know when it's gonna
you know yeah and they weren't wrong
about that and I had a great time um but
there's still a part of me that wishes
I'd gone to college you know what I mean
and like why am I now at 45 wanting to
do that you know or you want to go back
college now